[Music]
uh I think last time uh those who were
here we talked about uh one piece
dominating the other one it was night
over over the bishop uh tonight uh we
did we haven't talked in the in the in
the past two classes we haven't talked
about The Rook so we will do the piece
uh domination one over the other one but
I thought that we needed some to to add
some some Rook work so it builds upon
the other one so if you weren't here the
past two weeks we talked about peace
domination we talked about Bishop we
talked about Pawn endings we talked we
talked about Knight versus Bishop uh
that kind of thing uh and
uh and tonight we talk a little bit
about Rook which in my opinion is the
most difficult piece to
handle so so here we have this
position uh why not everyone take your
time and try try to assess this position
uh okay White's a pawn up obviously we
have three against
two uh we have this passer but this is a
way more dangerous passer
but there are so many catches here to
consider so let's talk about that so
what do you think what what is what is
what
makes uh what's what's the most
important advantage in White's position
white white is almost although these two
might the A and B
actually these two might be exchanged if
if we don't get to if we don't get to
have an active plan here
uh sorry I that
second and after
take yes and why is that why is that
good
yeah well we want to keep your your uh
your king over there because but then
you also give an F Pawn so let's go
through that and see what's what's going
to happen so F5 obviously King takes G6
not a good idea because of this and
again the A and B Pawn might exchange
and then you cannot win with a G or F
Pawn the king is close enough on E8 this
king is bad but not that bad because
it's Central on okay it has been pinned
as said to the back rank But Central so
it has enough time to reach the B Pawn
already at the G Pawn so it's very
important that we realize that having
our King active white king activity is
the most important thing I have three
rules if you want to write down for for
for the Rend Games
first active uh Advanced pawns active
active King and uh active active Rook is
more important than material sometime
those who were for the Rin robinin games
against lasar who who were here for the
for that game yes you were here if you
remember Robinson sacked the pawn just
to activate his King didn't drop the
Rook back to F1 to to maintain the other
Pawn so activity and having active
pieces is more is more
important so pass pawns active King
active rook and when you have a rook
there are two defensive ways with a rook
side checks and and attacking from
behind NE never only works on few cases
or that we if you get a time I would
like to talk about that's why I brought
this book from 1930s by rabinovic
because he explains it better than
anybody else in my opinion from
1930s uh yeah really uh I feel for
Rabino which he had a very he he had
four four daughters they all died during
the uh staling Leningrad uh sieg
yeah uh
so uh great great uh great book by
rabinovic and he explains when you
attack from this like France
like there's a Pawn on the uh most of
the time just if I want to explain that
let me put it on a new board I'm not
sure maybe white is already still
winning but if it's black to
move so we start giving checks this is a
defensive me method
not letting you pushing your Pawn but if
it was white to move I would have pushed
E5 KN if I put it
again if it was white to move white
would just simply push E5 and if check
go here if I want to step now it doesn't
work anymore now the king is too
close and the pawn will be promoted so
only in this case attacking from front
might work otherwise you want to have a
side checks or attacking from
behind so going back to our
position
uh uh here The Rook is from behind so
one way is that to create a shelter
that's why we play F5 as you mentioned
over there and then
G5 because if G takes
A5
now the King has an eye on this
guy and this guy and given our Rook is
Al active is pinned to this
Pawn we can hold B5 King C8 and
basically this King our King doesn't
cannot do much there
there and now the Rook cannot leave
leave leave the a file if I move my Rook
if I move my Rook along the along the
file this King comes to
B6 so The Rook is pined is tied to uh to
A6 the pawn is on B5 and I cannot get my
rook and you see how this attacking from
behind works
well but if I put a Pawn on G6 for black
I can just put my king on G7 and then
promote right you would love to have a
Pawn on G7 and the pawn on H7 that's why
we create that shelter we play F5 take
and then play G5 cuz that covers the
checks for
us any questions so far okay so far so
good so but that's just beginning of the
story so F4 there G7
F3 now how do you continue now time for
some excitement both PS are about to be
promoted
okay
Rook takes A2
right ah but don't think I'm I'm such
such an easy guy
F2 now what
next king E6 I go Rook G6 check and then
I
promote R A1 Rook G1 R F1 there you go
and and the truth
hurts oh he play Rook G3 but the point
is there and then Rook
F1 very the truth her big
time so Rook
G3 and
now there should be more than one by2 in
this
but
B Rook okay maybe maybe B5 B5 is we need
to uh I'm really worried about this
check
here check and if he go back is just a
draw if he go this way I might go King
F7 uh I don't know maybe maybe you have
winning chances maybe not because Rook
here here B6 I take B7 I go here and
that's a draw I think because if you go
there now again I have the same same
maneuver just like come forward making
that's
a but Rook F1 I want the
pawn he little bit repeated few moves
now if if I if you follow me I
go no now I I'm closer to my Pawn so
I'll be I'll be early enough so if I
give a
check I think I can go
here and this is winning because if you
give me a cheick I go King to G4 and now
you cannot stop me and your rookies
under attack so I can promote and if I
go King to F7
here I just grab this
Pawn
takes and I think if I put my Rook on
B2 I think I should be
winning there is no King E7 we push so
Rook E8 is forced and we play B6 and
this is winning because I I cannot play
King E7 there's rookie one rookie to
check so Rook
there am I
winning no it's a
draw so let's
see if check
again ah ah but your rookies away so I
can go King
D5 The Rook is away oh no now it's
working because I'm I'm I'm threatening
to push G8 check and now it's working
because now if it's to go
there okay this is winning we are in
place because if
check
int this is very important it's not cut
off cut off we have to cut off we have
we are we are on time to to cut off and
then the p and and also you're not in
time to get the rook in front because if
I
tried here I'm early enough to push the
pawn if you
go here also doesn't work
push King
B6 and this this pwn is going to be
promoted everybody knows the Len the how
to yeah to do the bridge right any
questions about that how to create a
bridge okay we're
good so if I want to use the notation
here Rook takes F2 Rook takes G7 there
check and our King well I think white
play a bit risky because if he hadn't
had after this move King C7 which
shoulders this King so our King is a
strong this king is a stop and this Pawn
is going to be promoted and the side
check doesn't work
because we always with a side check
always we get on the other side of the
pawn and then we push the pawn and uh
and again now we have the position we
just had in the other
analysis and Rook E6 and B5 and I think
that's game over any questions about
this one okay two simple ones
for the idea of once we play F5 how how
things get into the get get into the way
this one why to
move it's very important these two the
next two I'm showing you these are easy
ones but these are the patterns that
they repeat a lot in the in the Rook end
game and this is about when pieces get
into each other's
way this is why to play and when or Draw
uh I wish win but no it's draw to
draw I would like to see the kids if
they can find this one why to
play
uh this is why to
move why to play if I don't think he can
win it's a
draw yeah Rook
B4 because you are pushing it to the The
King The King runs in to a unwanted pin
and that's a
draw this is a
draw and this one okay this is not a
rook end game but the same same idea you
you you causes uh this is okay actually
black to move you you stop you stop a
you stop an
idea piece is running into each other's
way okay this is Bishop Bishop end game
I understand but the same
idea Bishop D3 Bishop
D3
yes yes sh yeah that's is to of Shir 3
yes but that one is very important the
the that one is very important because
Bishop on H3 also wins the tempo because
if I start coming with my king toward
the pawn here is is the same because
King F2 I start
pushing and this bishop is still
functioning and when the king is gets
here the king is within the square the
problem is that this is Bishop although
under attack for few moves is still
covering that so you cannot both
eliminate and get closer that's very
important so the same thing with the
with the with the toal of Shiro game is
that when you play Bishop H3 that Bishop
is hitting on G2 so you have to lose a
Tempo taking the bishop that important
Tempo becomes very very handy that's
very yes this bishop before kills the so
gets under each other's way so we stop
the E4 but there you give a check you
push the king to the pin how the piece
is getting in each other's
way okay this is pieces getting okay not
the idea
you the POS the positions we just looked
at are not exactly representing the idea
I wanted to uh the idea in this game but
somehow the pieces are in each other's
way in Black's position black is under
under tremendous attack because this
Rook is a strong along the along this
file along this uh rank our King is
caught this Pawn is under attack and
this Pawn is is weak too we are in
trouble how could
we how could black uh get the pieces off
of each other's way
here it's very interesting the idea in
this game
is very similar to the
idea uh I'm going to show you next game
uh robinin played against a player named
matis and uh okay matis wasn't in in
robinin level and he was only trying to
make a draw in a better position and
what happened he lost but uh Robin found
the idea in this game a player of the
level of was couldn't find he's a super
grandmas 27 between 2730
2750 so very difficult
position what is on the way of our Rook
on C6 what's
wrong
what king f8 and then Rook
H7 what's that E5 oh very good
job this is a bad move the right move is
King f8 Rook H7 and E5 the pawn should
be get off the way of this TR now this
TR has enough space to maneu along the
rank and speaking of the ways to defend
what was one of the ways to have have
activity along the along the rank so
E5 so if D take E5 look
there and we're
happy we are very happy right in time
right and uh if King there okay I we
look at this and if uh Rook D okay Rook
D7 is more challenging of course take
take Rook E6 and R goes to E4 we have
enough
activity is this
here it's not
M okay
good because I don't have internet here
on this laptop so okay so what happened
in the game is
that goes Rook B6 King C3 Rook
A6
now uh what should be the winning plan
for
white so the point is
here King B4
yeah combining attack and defense this
Rook wanted to come to A3 now we want to
play King B5 winning this Pawn but this
and this there's a key move this is the
key move now the the ensuing uh Pawn
ending is losing only one tempo only we
had that one moment to get
Activity one more time in The Rook end
game activity is the first thing you
have to
consider and the end game oh and of
course everybody's familiar with
the
opposition
there and
then King D6 and that's G over now let's
see now I think this is a bit
easier so I set up the position and
let's see how
um robinin
handled well the his problem was much
less than
Wass not the same degree of complexity
and not the same kind of opponent
but
okay black has a weak Pawn on D6 white
has better pawn and structure on the
king
side but in few moves wiin ends White's
advantage and actually starts to play
for a win why should be Black's moveing
this position and after that what should
Black's plan to improve his
position those who were here last week
we looked at Khan against the capablanca
we were not done with it we'll look at
it again
here this
PL so how should black continue first
here to Sol it's not a big problem D6
you can play King C7 always defend your
Pawn but it's it's a sort of position
you want to get after few moves and then
how you want to improve after
that what that Rook
E5 now I don't have any worries I just I
just need to keep my King close to my
Pawn which is which is after that is
close to this close to is also in the
center so take the king
D7 and here so the King goes to this D7
to E6 The Rook is free and what what is
what is further more to be done
E6 F5 because if I if I manage to get
rid of this Pawn then I have a majority
uh four against three of course why will
have a three against two but then I'll
have an active
plan I I'm undering play G4 or something
yes white should have played G4 here but
white plays C4 so what do you think
about this move is it a good move a very
bad move a big mistake or an average
mistake or just just normal move white
play C
C4 what's with
C4 an open file uh that's right what
else that's not good enough well that's
that's well no there's that's that's
good the thing is it's all good but
there is something there's
something uh after that yeah what
happens after the open
file that's right the the point is B5
but what happens after B5 and B3 and the
The Exchange because the pawn is still
on C4
yeah Rook
B right right but that that pawn is
still on C4 prevents D5 but what why
Rook B4 The Rook can't put that I put
the King on C3
okay does C4 stop your plan G6 F5 or it
doesn't my point that's my question
no it doesn't stop that why it doesn't
stop that because we want to do that
then eventually playing D5 but now c4
Rook D5 is kind of seem seems very solid
but there's something wrong with
it6 no no no B5 was correct B take C4 is
going to happen you're going to occupy
the B5 maybe at some point or maybe
not
what is the point of Rook E8 Rook
E5 all right just one thing needs to be
one thing need to be said when you once
you play C4 and once you exchange E
Pawn once we exchange these two pieces
these two pawns F6 once and once we we
exchange the Rooks as you said D5
creates a pass pump for us not just
majority that's a huge difference and
that's why that's a very once we we
exchange the D6 Pawn with a C4 Pawn then
C Pawn becomes a pass pawn and in the
pawn End Game Pass pawns are extremely
important not majority majority is not a
pass Pawn it's a different thing when
the pawn is on C2 if you exchange you
four against three is a majority when
you have a Pawn on C4 and all the
exchange is happening when the Rooks are
off the board D5 results into having a
pass B which is a very important thing
as and as you can see how uh White goes
down because of the pass B so in the end
game do not bring the I would say it's
it's like it's like a spear and it's the
tip of the spear it's the head of a
spear don't bring the head of a spear or
the your Pawn chain just very close to
your opponent because if the exchanges
are happening at the result of the pawn
exchanges you might your oppon might
might be left with with the passp you do
it unless you have advantage on the site
and what didn't have any advantage on
that side his Advantage as you mentioned
was on the king side with G4 H4 and
trying to although this should still be
an equal one but you could exert some
pressure with G4 H4 H5 gaining some
space bring the king to
F4 I don't know maybe H6 happens but
then maybe go the other way wait for
black to see what's going to happen then
maybe F4 you know that's where you have
Advantage do not play on your opponent's
side and that's a big mistake that's why
so B5 right but after that it's very
important point is that after all the
exchanges black will be left with ad
with past C Pawn that's very important
very subtle
so uh Robin didn't have a problem to
play can we see that actually played out
sorry I'm going to show the game rest
the game sorry can you actually show us
now that what I'm going to show the
again yeah sure yeah I was not going to
stop I just
one there's there's so many ways to show
it but I thought that we would follow
none other than Mr rinin himself
so so here oh uh King C2 King
E6 uh King C3 F5 so the first phase
completed right we wanted to have the
pawn on F5 e takes F5 G takes F5 okay
now we have we have we have four against
three majority Rook goes back to D2 B5
B3
uh okay now we know so we will have D5
will have B Tak c b Tak C and
D5 but is it the time to do it or we
have to do something else at this
moment the thing is that we also now
have this open file over here but can we
use
it if you push F4
and so SL over so play
G3 F4 then you have to think of G4
because if you take the H takes and my
pawns are kind of solid your H7 Pawn is
kind of a little bit
undermined I'm not sure I'm not saying
F4 is a decisive mistake or anything but
you want to be very careful because
you're playing for Advantage so every
move it's either the advantage is gone
or you're a little bit adding to your
pressure the position is objectively
equal
H H5 yes what's the what is the ensuing
idea what's after that what's after
H5 fix the G2 pawn and maybe Rook G8
maybe H F4 and H4 now you want to play
H3 and if you take so the idea is that I
want I would like to have
this and H3 because if you take then I
go rook h8 and then I grab the pawn and
put more pressure and if H3 then then
the vice majority is dead so you're
killing Vice majority then your D5
becomes much more stronger exactly H5
very good move let me there there number
of moves here I have to add some
exclamation
mark uh through
E5 and uh also G6
F5 and
B5
that makes a lot of exclamation
marks okay
H5
uh so here uh really okay now G3 white
is trying to to stop now it's time to
calculate now why's trying to why's
trying to stop uh Black's advancement
trying which would fix White's King side
and as a result we will have a safe
majority on the Queen side we could just
slowly pushing so white tries to create
something
but but
what you have to figure there's
something wrong with G3 again same
similar to to C4 as I told you C4
brought the the head of the pawn chain
too too close so that we could you know
we could attack it the same thing is
happening
here and if I
take and if I play Rook e to check
well your idea was right just why King
D7 King F5 F4 is the best
move G takes F4 if happens in the game
black played white play
check King there and we we will look at
this later on but if G takes F4 Rook f8
Rook E2 cheick and I go King F5 and I
I'm trying now to actually win all these
pawns and if Rook e four I'm kind of
safe safe here I don't see anything that
would worry me and I can go Rook G8
now why still should be able to keep it
with active play I I believe so but now
now there are things he has to handle he
has Rook G2 is coming if he goes back
take King takes A4 is coming so it's not
going to be that
easy so that's why he played
this now we have this position now black
to move this position
so well obviously Rook Rook can go to G8
right attacking the pawn Rook F4 check
King E6 Rook E4
check King
D7 and uh
here white has to concede to grab this H
Pawn give up these two pawns and try to
defend four against three
instead got to bit greedy and play
G4 now what can we do H H4 ah yes pass
Pawn yes pass
Pawn we don't afid we're not afraid of
Pawn instruct or anything pass Pawn
always rook and Game Pass
Pawn so
H4 uh White tried to play A4 B takes C4
B takes
C4 and now actually not B take C4
actually B take A4 this is even more
accurate because B takes C4 there could
be some King takes C4 so you try to
avoid that as well now
here and
now and now what should we
do now now I'm afraid a little bit to to
talk some giant is here so I'm little
bit try to be careful with my content
yeah Rook f8 yes
yes oh actually I'm sorry I think here
we could actually include this earlier
and then play H4 because if
take I can take check and after King
goes back here we can play Rook H3 and
we can play four against three
but
uh my long ago long time ago analysis
tells me that this is the best practical
way to make a
draw this I'm not sure if he can hold so
H4 A4 which is another bad another bad
move in this position it's a waste of
time we have to think we have to think
of doing something about this Pawn
either bringing the king although we
don't want to really bring this King
over here because it it stops this King
this Rook from going E1 and going to H1
in the meantime I don't know we have to
do something about this Pawn but A4 is
just a waste of time so B take A4 B
takes
A4 oops
and
and now uh black to move H3 H3 I can
play
four uh then you have a three against
two with good winning chances but I
think after if H3 F4 Rook takes F4 Rook
takes H3 Rook takes G and I might go a
can I go A5 Rook G1 is a little bit
dangerous but no I I think I can go A5
and now I am threatening to play Rook H7
I'm going a seven and I have I think too
much activity and one Pawn is not enough
material to win this but again what was
our rules think about our three rules in
The Rook end
game you don't want to give give up that
pawn that
easily Rook F4 interesting Rook F4 is an
interesting
move I can go sorry r h Rook h8 I go
Rook E2 I'll be passive Rook H
interesting I'll be pass it but then
I'll have F4 and G4 and it's not that
easy for your king to come close to the
H
Pawn H H3 if we play4 Rook h8 I go Rook
to E1 and H2 I go Rook H1 your King
again cannot get close that
easily
although with a little bit of Adventure
I checked I was playing with with
stockfish is still winning but it's a
little bit adventurous about R E8 can't
exchange
Rooks square and if I play Rook King to
D2 if I play
here and King to D2 and then
what
um and if I play Oh h
H3 I can go Rook to B3 I think and H2
then I can go Rook
B1 and
then and then D5 there you go remember I
said why C4 was a bad move because you
bring the you bring the head of the
spear the the the pawn chain in front so
and now after D5 as I told you earlier
we have a pass Pawn not just a majority
that's a huge difference so exactly Rook
takes Rook King takes here and then D5
and black resigned white resigned
sorry so how many rules we created we
have we created too many I think I broke
bang fal's record on that making making
rules so on the side that we are weaker
we would not push
pawns because then we can give the
chance
to uh to your opponent for the counter
and uh as you can see if this Pawn
wasn't still I don't think it matter
here but if this spawn was on
C2 uh black should have white should
have had a chance to
hold uh and the what the other one was
that the pawn that the uh the pass Pawn
you want to have a pass Pawn so H4 we
try to have a pass PA the other one was
activity we we we try to in the in the
opening in the in the opening scenario
we exchange and we activated our king
that's what white had to do instead
white played C4 wasted a very very
precious time and then we centralize our
King and then we play the
five it was because we had an active
King because King is AC defending this
Pawn letting this Rook maneuver along
the uh this Rank and you know if we have
to occupy the gall and sometimes we have
to occupy the ball which wasn't the case
in this
game so actually the final uh just for
sorry here is the final position have to
take and I can go H3 there and C4 and as
you can see it's quite wide open that
King cannot handle both and uh this Pawn
is a Tempo
behind so if because another important
thing is that if
G5
um our King is within in the reach of
this Pawn so I can just take on C4 it's
one of the many ways to win and after G6
I just go King E7 and again the pawns
are two further
away so this uh example of two far past
pawns reminds me of this famous end game
by
nimich how many have seen this position
before so is Rook D2 a good move or not
a good
move it's a
draw how
come and take and
then King E4 and I play B6 G3 B7 G2 let
me show it on the
board
we'll look at that
too and
uh and I think
uh we will have some winning chances
after this
check just after King F3 don't play King
D3 because despite this check there's
this nasty check on E3 that that ruins
the day but I'm not sure maybe it's it's
it's it's a it's at least a draw
it's at least a
draw but uh it's maybe just a
draw so King E4 so King
D5 so what about this one
interesting so let's say play
B6 you have to go King C6 right and then
I go F5 and I think promote at the same
time and I don't think you have any
specific mate
threat
oh
and I don't think that pawn and queen
going to mate
me are they going to mate me I don't
think
so but think about
just what we just looked at in the
previous game the final final
position black obviously will create two
farther pass Pond the the actually the
the uh the Roski has this rule of five
and seven that's too complicated for me
so I just start counting so
after uh
he was counting the number of squares in
front and and the number of uh the
number of Falls part the pawns are and
the number of squares in front of them
to to promote and he said if the number
is bigger than something seven or five
it's winning or if it's not if the king
can going go both both way and capture
both PMS so after here we know that
after F4 it's going to be two squares in
between two two files in between and
then there are three here there are
three squares here and then three here
that's quite a number of of of squares
so it's probably should be winning the
problem is that with with the problem is
with White's Pawn being
active what's
that
A5 oh no I don't play B6 I play if any
play King D5 King D6 there was King D3
King D5 go a five and now I want A6
because my immediate th is A6 and
actually I'm going to promote the pawn
with a check on A8 so that would cost
you another
Tempo
yeah you're playing then I no then I
play B6 and then you go King C6 and I go
King D3 F4 I just grab on D4 and then
actually
that's that's a no that's not winning
because after F3 King I have to go back
King D3 let me show you so if I go here
you take King takes on D2 if you go King
D5
um I go
A5 so King C5 you go I
go can I should go a okay
B6 can I does it matter I I I thought it
should be winning but King
C6 King D3
F4 can I take because if I take it's
going to be a
draw
uh take
G3 I think I should concede to a draw
here really doesn't matter but maybe you
can look for more this one is a
draw H okay
F4 you include that that's very
important Tempo because this Pawn on F4
is not fast enough is not is not
Advanced compared to our Pawn on G4 and
after G takes F4 we
go King D6 now remember in the very
first one when I was showing you in in
hushim game the The Very the very first
one when I said the King was on E8 isn't
a bad piece that that much because it
was covering both the pawn on B4 and G4
G4 if if you remember it was so this
King
now uh first of all this Pawn is way too
far so if I go A5 we go G3 A6 and we go
King
C7 and this Pawn's going to be
promoted and if I try to run like both
both of these pawns D and G and then uh
five G3 F6 G2 still too late
so another Choice could be
B6 G
G3 I think that's way too me and if King
to E2 I'm trying to stop that then D3
check the King on D6 and similar to the
previous and and remember uh the first
one I said that King on E8 covers both B
and G Pawn so this this has
this controls this Pawn these two guys
and this Pawn as well this is a key
score any questions about this
one I think that was that was what I had
for
today thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
aah